the cinemasins podcast is finally here
we're going at the sin cast because
branding is easy and we're lazy for some
of you this means nothing but to those
of you who might actually want to listen
to us talk about movies we hope it comes
as good news you know it's exciting for
our first three episodes Chris and I are
joined by Barrett one of the writers of
music video sins and our very good
friend he's my friend future episodes
we'll also include J the other music
video sins writer and many other special
guests hello Marsha let's get better we
plan to talk movies television music and
music videos on a regular basis button
there Quincy
judging by the first three episodes we
will generally tackle a single topic per
episode
the first is us telling the cinemasins
story of how we met and ultimately
started the channel the second is force
awakens discussion both spoiler free and
spoiler filled sections clearly marked
and the third is a discussion of the
most sinful moments in movies from 2015
also judging from the first taping we
will end up talking about Kenneth
Branagh for some reason Haim and
remember the hamlet trailer actually do
you know Warner Brothers pictures
presents you know a new film from
Kenneth Branagh based on the best work
by William Shakespeare and it's like you
know Robin Williams Billy Crystal Derek
Jacobi you know for your source and I
when we send it over to Jeremy I did
Jacobi first cuz didn't you yeah
the podcast is free and can be found on
iTunes and SoundCloud with links on our
website to both the first episode is
live now click the annotation or the
link in the description below we are
also asking for questions as we hope to
do a short fan question segment at the
end of each episode moving forward the
worst episode ever so what're you
waiting for go listen to audio while you
run or fix engines or change diapers or
operate dangerous machinery whatever you
do for a living or for fun the sink cast
will only improve it good
let the heat flow through you